and an English scone with butter and jam
we put the jam on top of the cream whose
idea was that
well that's ridiculous
who does that my name is Steve Coogan
and this is snack wars for lad Bible and
the food under this is what you call
these what a clock have a new that and
fifty for food beneath this clock is
Greek and British because I've been
filling grease from the film called
greed and greedy people are people who
just eat lots of food
greedy people are people like who is
worth 2.6 billion pounds and employs
people on four dollars a day in
sweatshops
in places like Sri Lanka Bangladesh and
what they do is the city then the
employees people for no money and that's
why they're so wealthy and really it's
just so she ate cheapo debating paying
for for people who have no running water
who pay less than $4 a day that's greed
now another kind of greed is this
this is Thomas alotta if I'm not
mistaken and a bit of pizza bread which
technically read those and an English
scone with butter and jam when you put
the jam on top of the cream whose idea
was that
well that's ridiculous
who does that
[Laughter]
without one it's come overall some
George's flag about it this guns
obviously malls better okay
yeah so this is sesame seeds on and it's
a great and there's a giant Bourbon
Street cookies I don't know they are
we've got some more and one of his big
it's like more of mediocrity about
cinnamon and obviously yeah the horrible
but you know the bobbin is slightly that
over spam and I'm not eating that
I'm not eating either of these I'll look
at them very funny though tins of
unappetizing seafood and I mean you
probably could be a vegetarian and eat
scram there's a lot of meat in it
so yes the winner in in this particular
test was the the my choice was the
British choice so yes so these high
street fashion brands what they do is
they distract you by using celebrities
Philip Green these throw those parties I
will say to it like celebrity fans out
there be very careful at who you take
your money from and if that annoys you I
don't care
you should be annoyed you should think
everybody you work for right homebrew
and
Luc's if you Luke looks lovely
it's great strapline isn't it yeah
neither we're going to win prizes for
organic sustainability yeah I probably
have iron brew because parties made from
girders holding that are any kind of
weird nationalistic fervor
despite the march of right-wing populism
across Europe I'm not part of it so this
is Steve Coogan doing snack wars for the
lad Bible okay now you have to keep all
that stuff in a Cell about if you cut
all that and just up the food [ __ ] and
I'll go [ __ ] but I'll kill someone
right okay
[Music]